9 sally backt sie ist die torten queen
im internet jetzt packt sie ihre
meisterwerke bei uns jeder folge ein
kind in meiner kirche einladen gemeinsam
backen sie dann eine überraschung
traumtore nicht links menschen doch wie
sagt man eine eule oder einen
schminkkoffer das schlimmste glaube ich
bin vom entwurf bis zum finish sally
zeigt wie es geht
ich weiß auch wie hat mitzumachen
ab sonntag 15 uhr bei vox
den trailer habt ihr vielleicht schon im
fernsehen gesehen der läuft schon seit
einigen tagen auch und auch und viele
unserer zuschauer freuen sich bereits
auf die sendung hier in diesem video
möchte ich gerne wissen was zum
hintergrund meiner wachs sendung sagen
und erzählen und euch einen kleinen
blick hinter die kulissen geben genaue
hintergrund eine küchenmaschine
bereinigt lägen in sacrow und den
hintergrund von der sendung das war uns
auch ehrlich sagen dhb heißes ding ich
habe vor fünf jahren mit meinen youtube
videos angefangen damals hat es hier
noch nicht so aus ich hatte nämlich nur
dieser kamera das war meine
digitalkamera die ich mir auch studenten
leisten konnte habt ihr dann auf dem
karton gestellt und den muss oft gefilmt
und dann habe ich genau vier mal gemacht
weil mich morath jedes mal ausgedacht
hat und gesagt hat was machst du
eigentlich da in der küche genau und ich
fand dass man das aber lustig weil ich
wusste damals nicht versuchst du bist
oder allgemeine social media bei ich hab
noch normales leben gehabt
juni social media und das bist du ein
social media experte ja und das war dann
einfach ich wollte einfach meine park
und kochleidenschaft mit meinen mensch
mit menschen teilen und habe wirklich
super gerne gebacken gekocht
hauswirtschaft studiert im rahmen eines
lehramtsstudiums und habe gedacht mensch
es vielen einfach irgendwie back und
kochanleitungen die jeder nachmachen
kann mit etwas hintergrundwissen wo
kommen die zutaten her
wie läuft die zubereitung und so weiter
ja und da habe ich dann die kamera
einfach in die hand genommen und habe
sie hier vorne auf einem karton drauf
gestellt und habe dann einfach losgelegt
so sah das ganze dann aus ich weiß die
lichtverhältnisse waren damals nicht so
gut der turm war der ton war auch nicht
so toll aber die rezepte waren schon
immer gut erprobt und gelingt sicher und
das war mir einfach wichtig also habe
ich einfach mit den videos weitergemacht
weil super viel spaß gemacht hat
ich habe nebenher studiert samira
großgezogen erzogen da muss ich sagen
ich war auch schon dort ist auch
schaffen will und ja hab das ganze
parallel damit zu meinem studium gemacht
und heute stehen wir hier wir sind auch
damals zweimal umgezogen und
letztendlich in dieser küche weil hier
einfach ein super licht ist wir konnten
hier dieser arbeitsplatte machen also
die küchen insel wo man einfach alles
super profit und ich hab dann die videos
von einem video im monat auf drei bis
vier in der woche erhöht und das war
schon so ein schritt muss ich sagen was
dazu beigetragen hat dass der
youtube-kanal eben auch größer wurde
doch das erste video sehen das war eine
lust ob bis jetzt und haben das alles
mitverfolgt
er ist eigentlich angewachsen ist wie
die qualität besser wurde ja damals habe
ich alles habe wurde er wird immer
besser machen ja wie ein guter wein gern
dort steuern besser mit dem jahren genau
und ulmer korb doch mal sagen wir jetzt
nichts am anfang habe ich die videos
selber gedreht und auch geschnitten habe
das ganze dann an meinem laptop gemacht
mir selber tutorials angeschaut wie man
videos schneidet und heute bin ich ganz
froh dass sich ein team um mich herum
habt das habe ich mit den jahren
aufgebaut wir hatten vor drei jahren
noch keine party mitglieder
dann kam der allererstes war der frank
der hat dann die kamera gemacht hat dann
den schnitt gemacht ja mit der zeit sind
wir an gewachsen und haben jetzt stolze
30 mitarbeitern oder teammitglieder und
es ist alles wirklich spontan auch
entstanden aus dem freundes auch alles
sein es gibt nichts zu tun hatte kann
man sagt komm mit disco kampf wir haben
mit kuchenbuffet
es ist ja und das ist echt schöne kleine
sally familie zu haben jeder kennt den
handgriff vom anderen und wir sind ein
super eingespieltes team
oder sind wir doch sehr viel spaß hier
ja und dann kamen schon vor drei jahren
die ersten angebote aus dem fernsehen zu
einer eigenen fernsehsendung
ich weiß noch in meiner küche die wir
vorher hatten habe ich schon ein video
gemacht was haltet ihr von der
fernsehsendung das problem war einfach
immer nur dass die fernsehsender uns
vorschreiben wollten was wird reden wo
wir drehen
meist eben in berlin köln oder münchen
in den filmstudios und es war einfach
für mich nicht möglich
wegen den kindern wegen der familie und
ich habe auch vor drei jahren noch als
lehrerin gearbeitet also ich hätte ja
nicht einfach wegfahren können
und vor allem wollten wir nicht nach
einem drehbuch arbeiten denn es sollte
einfach authentisch bleiben hier in
meiner küche
ich möchte gerne das backen und kochen
was ich möchte keine dinge benutzen die
uns ja die mir nicht gefallen
und so ähnlich war es zum beispiel auch
mit unseren büchern und wir hatten immer
den ansporn alles selber zu machen weil
wir so die zügel selber in der hand
haben und eben auch selbst bestimmen
können was in den halter sind ja bei dem
buch war es ja auch so mal kurz stehen
alle vier aber ich sage ich mal das
allererste also da bin ich heute auch
noch mega stolz drauf
es kamen ganz viele große buchverlage
auf uns zu die kennt ihr auch alle von
vielen back und kochbüchern und ja uns
alle angebotenen kommt der liebe machen
ein buch für dich und ja wir haben uns
dann angehört was wollten sie uns geben
die wir wollten mit die rezepte stellen
die fotografie also den fotografen aus
rohr der die texte über mich schreibt
und auch den druck bezahlen und das
wollten wir alle nicht denn ich wollte
keine rezepte überhaupt veröffentlichen
die nicht von mir sind alle denke ich
mir selber aus und nicht abhob sie und
macht sie und probierte aus für euch und
fotografen hatten wir zu der zeit schon
werden da den mars schon kenne 90 jahre
jung ja der war damals 20 und echt super
also ja der kommt aus heidelberg war
auch so ein zufallstreffer sozusagen wir
haben uns gleich super gut verstanden
und er macht einfach echt die schönsten
bilder also alle bilder die wir hier
drin haben auch in anderen büchern aus
der küche sind hier aus der küche sind
alle die im studio sind auf dem
küchentisch entstanden ja an ihrem
küchentisch amiras schreibt bücher
anschauen
ja ich wirklich alles hier aus dem
wohnzimmer
wir haben alles im wohnzimmer genau uns
ja und die rezepte habe ich dann selber
geschrieben marius hat die fotos gemacht
wir haben das buch dann auch selber
gesetzt und die druckkosten konnten wir
im prinzip auch selber übernehmen weil
wir auch schon seit vier jahren unseren
eigenen online shop haben wir uns dann
nur für einen ganz ganz kleinen verlag
entschieden und war ist es der echt
lecker verlag bzw herder-verlag das war
eine zuschauerin von uns die simone
die uns mal zwei drei kinderbücher
geschickt hat für samira und das hat uns
so gut gefallen sie macht es ganz
alleine und ist sozusagen ihr eigener
arbeitgeber selbstständig und mama ihr
habt noch neben mir alles genau arbeitet
bei altersheim gearbeitet
und ja mit ihr zusammen haben wir das
gemacht weil sie eben die erfahrung auch
beim druck und so weiter hat und mit ihr
haben wir die bücher gemacht ja und so
will mit den büchern
also dieses selber machen war auch der
ansporn bei uns fürs fernsehen
das waren wirklich sehr sehr viele
fernsehsender bei uns wir waren auch
dort hatten ganz viele gespräche und im
prinzip hat uns eigentlich immer nur
gestört dass man uns sagen wollte was
wir tun müssen welche back produkte wir
verwenden sollen welche maschinen und so
weiter also ein bisschen vermarkten
wollten sie uns eigentlich alle und
natürlich auch die vermarktungsrechte
unten drehbuch und das war halt was wo
ich gesagt das passt nicht zu uns wir
müssen authentisch bleiben
ich wollte einfach so bleiben wie ich
bin wo hat mit dabei das stricken lassen
kann bei uns hier in der küche dass ich
eben weiterhin kind familie und beruf
unter einen hut bekomme und dann hatten
wir das war ja dieses jahr vor ein paar
monaten grad erst im gespräch bei vox
und zwar hat uns da unser netzwerk was
uns betreut das sbw hof in berlin
und die haben einfach sagt kommt es geht
um hatte vox wir haben ein gespräch für
euch und habt euch doch mal an diana
dahin und ich muss sagen ich hatte keine
erwartungen weil eigentlich mal wieder
voll ausgelastet wie in unserem youtube
videos mit den büchern die wir machen im
bau also eigentlich hatten wir keine
zeit für eine fernsehsendung jahren auch
schon gedacht dass ich wieder genug die
wohl neue ist von hagens verändert er
und im gegenzug war es aber genauso also
display der sender vox hat dann auch
gesagt jetzt kommt da so eine youtube
und eigentlich hatten wir keine
erwartungen voneinander und dann war das
aber echt ein super cooles gespräch also
haben uns vorgestellt und sie haben sich
vorgestellt und es hat einfach gut
gemacht und das war wirklich so sie
haben gesagt mensch sally macht noch
macht doch einfach was ihr wollt macht
eure sendung backwards bleibt
authentisch macht keine show sondern
macht eine richtig echte bugs sendung
und so haben wir es gemacht und ich fand
den anreiz ganz voll
die sendung sieht so aus ich lade in
jeder sendung also wir haben vier stück
gemacht und den jungen gast zu mir in
die küche ein und back dann mit ihm
gemeinsam oder mit ihr gemeinsam eine
richtig tolle motiv torte und mit dieser
torte darf der junge gast an einem
besonderen menschen überraschen
und es ist wirklich schön ist auch was
emotionale ist kurz vor weihnachten
finde ich sehr schön und vor allem hatte
ich die möglichkeit einfach menschen
glücklich zu machen und es hat wirklich
gut funktionieren
es ist kein wettbewerb genauso ist wie
ich und zeit wenn sie ja einfach immer
überraschend genau einfach ein paar tage
zusammen und backen und dekorieren und
dann jemanden überraschen und das fanden
wir wirklich sehr schön und es waren
wirklich super kandidaten dabei und wir
haben natürlich ein großes
auswahlverfahren muss ich sagen das
haben sich ganz ganz viele tolle
menschen beworben aber ihr müsst auch
verstehen falls ihr euch jetzt nicht
genommen haben dass ich eben auch nur
vier sendungen jetzt erstmal habe und
das hat einfach ass hat vieles mit
reingespielt was eben ja zeit und so
weiter an fahrt und deswegen muss man
jetzt erstmal auf 4 beschränken
und ich denke es ist ganz cool genau wie
es weitergeht haben wir noch einmal
macht gucken genau jetzt erzählen wir
euch ein bisschen was zur
entstehungsgeschichte wird film und das
ganze natürlich auch hier von zu hause
aus mit einem kamerateam das ist zum
beispiel dass er maximal klingt mal
nicht so ernst er hat hier die kamera
auf dem slider und diese kamera nimmt
dann zum beispiel die schönen aufnahmen
mit damit zeigen wir auch die zutaten
und es ist echt immer ein richtig cooler
effekt das ist übrigens der partie
er hat die große klappe und er
organisiert zum beispiel auch den
transfer von den gästen dass die hier
ankommen dass eine hotelübernachtung
haben und so weiter also da muss
natürlich auch alles organisiert werden
und es ist nicht einfach in einer sei es
besser wir haben wir nur ein hotel
der senat hat übrigens nicht nur die
aufgabe als kameramann sondern ist auch
der transporter wir backen in dieser
sendung viele große und schwere torten
und ich wollte einfach nicht dass meine
gäste die torten tragen müssen
das heißt sie mag war dann immer unser
transporter hat die torten von a nach b
transportiert und ob er sie immer sage
ich mal sicher
gut hinbekommen hat das sehen wir dann
teilweise hatte er ja auch 300 bis 350
kilometer autofahrt das war schon immer
so ein bisschen wacklig ist ja so dass
ich eigentlich schauen du darfst nicht
fahren da eine ganz kurze geschichte von
drei jahren habe ich eine motiv torte
oder eine buttercremetorte für meine
freundin gebacken zum fünfzigsten und
der geburtstagsfeier war nur fünf
kilometer weit weg und ja murat ist mit
30 gefahren aber am ende in der kurve zu
schnell gefahren und zack war der
teppich habe zwei jahre lang ausgebildet
haben mir die fahrsicherheitstrainings
gemacht und er hat damit ich geb's zu
tricksen also das rohe eier
transportieren
genau das ist okay so gut der dann hoffe
ich mal dass ist alles gut gelaufen ist
[Musik]
man will
ja dann haben wir hier noch den tomtom
ist unser haupt kameramann der hat immer
noch die große kamera die auf mich
gerichtet ist und fängt natürlich auch
immer die emotionen ein tom gerade so ja
beim kennenlernen also wenn die gäste zu
mir nach hause kommen und mich das erste
mal sehen oder auch bei der übergabe der
torten es war schon immer ziemlich
schwierig und ich meinte hatte ich ja
immer nur eine chance das festzuhalten
wie war das für dich
es ist schon ein bisschen eine
herausforderung gewesen auf jeden fall
weil wir ja nur diese eine einzige
chance hatten die emotionen festzuhalten
und wer wusste auch gar nicht wie die
beschenkten reagieren und das war schon
sehr interessant
ich habe ihn auch nicht unter druck
gesetzt haben sagt tom wenn du den einen
moment nicht einverstanden und dann und
da war auch jemand nicht mehr erkannt
dass eine torte war das dürfen jetzt
nicht zu viel verraten aber einmal war
tatsächlich sieht das war ein bisschen
herausforderungen dann denjenigen zu
erklären das ist was es war das ist
sagen wir mal erkennt ja auch die torten
nicht immer sofort alles erst mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja und dann haben wir noch den marius
der nicht nur unsere fotos macht sondern
auch als kameramann hier tätig war
er hatte nämlich die zweite kamera hat
das ganze immer so ein bisschen in der
totalen aufgenommen also was wo man
einfach ein bisschen mehr sieht weiß ich
schon die dritte kammer war schon die
dritte genau also jahr bei uns was an
die kamera 1 der torkamera 2 marcel
mathis und camera 3 sehr mag und kamera
vier haben wir noch kamera 4 ist die da
oben das ist eine auf dem stativ da
haben wir natürlich immer die torte und
das geschehen hier so ein bisschen im
blick und dann aber noch eine kamera und
zwar ist die hier oben oder auch
beweglich die war teilweise im
kühlschrank oder auch im backofen dass
es so eine action cam die wir auch immer
gerne benutzen weil sie sehr flexibel
und variabel ist und falls ja wo mal
extern einfach unsere kameratechnik
sehen wollt dann machen wir mal ein
extra video oder aber ich bin schon
ziemlich interessant vor allem war das
ja auch für mich alles neuland ich habe
auch alles selber lernen müssen
und ja wie war dann von dieser kamera zu
dieser kameratechnik gekommen sind
können euch dann separat mal zeigen
fotos macht zwischen marius urmann
collegen fotografien treffen ja so
machen wir das jetzt sagt ihr die ganzen
kamera für sehen jetzt fehlt natürlich
auch noch der schnitt und ich muss sagen
dass schnitt das war schon ziemlich
heftig wenn man überlegt so von anfang
bis ende also wirklich von der planung
der sendung über den dreh über den
schnitt bis ganz zum fertigen
endresultat war es dann wirklich um 15
uhr bei vox läuft hat mir wirklich pro
folge etwa vier wochen arbeitszeit um
das in vollbeschäftigung und ganz
alleine hätten wir das nie geschafft und
ich bin froh dass ich echt mein team um
mich herum habe jeder hat seine aufgabe
jeder spielt im anderen zu unserer
wirklich ein super eingespieltes team
und hat super viel spaß gemacht für euch
zuhause verändert sich im prinzip nichts
für uns war es einfach nur eine längere
produktionszeit youtube videos waren
bisher immer ein bisschen schneller
hergestellt vor allem hatte ich auch
keinen gast hier zu hause in meiner
küche und das wort schon schön also es
war auch mal eine schöne erfahrung für
mich und für uns und natürlich auch für
euch und ja das einzige was ich dann
noch verändert außerdem ganz bei mir in
der küche ist einfach nur dass er dann
bei vox zwei werbeunterbrechungen habt
und das kommt einfach so zustande ihr
müsst euch vorstellen pro folge haben
wir vier wochen
zeit und natürlich haben auch die bei
vox ihre arbeitszeit und viele die da
eben auch noch mitwirken müssen und es
muss einfach finanziert werden ich meine
das ist ja normal privaten sender das
ist privat sein dass ich gebühren
finanzieren
die leute schreiben ist eine
werbeunterbrechung klar denn man zieht
ist irgendwie gerne und es muss auch das
muss finanziert sein das heißt woher
diese finanzierung wäre gar kein sender
auf markt muss ja auch sagen wer kein
fußballverein auf dem fußballfeld wenn
du schon säuren nicht werden
das muss man einfach so sehen genau
jeder schafft bezahlt werden ja man kann
sehr positiv sehen in der zeit kann man
kurz auf die toilette und verpassten
extra sendung und machten auch werbung
schon man kann auch die namen anschauen
können ja und jetzt wo wir auch den
schnitt angesprochen haben also ich habe
wirklich nach sind drehtagen wir haben
teilweise von 8 bis 18 uhr gefilmt
wirklich vom aufbau bis zum abbau und
natürlich habe ich zwischendurch auch
noch unsere kinder gesehen das ist ja
auch ganz wichtig hatte dann immer mal
zwischendurch pause und nach dem dreh
wenn die kids dann im bett waren also
wir haben wirklich zu unseren normalen
familienalltag abgeschlossen halb acht
die kinder ins bett und um 8 bin ich
dann noch zum schnitt gefahren zum frank
der wohnt ja bei uns gerade im
nachbarort da unsere büros noch nicht
fertig sind muss er leider noch zu hause
schneiden und dann haben wir wirklich es
teilweise bis mitte ihn danach noch die
videos geschnitten und die folgen und
das ist auch sehr wichtig weil ich dann
immer sagen konnte mensch dieser schritt
weit sehr wichtig dieser schritt war
vielleicht nicht so wichtig und man hat
wirklich aus zwölf stunden rohmaterial
was wir über die ganzen tage gefilmt
haben muss man einen 46 minuten film
schneiden und das ist wirklich eine
richtig richtig große herausforderung
also welcher schritt ist wichtig welcher
ist vielleicht unwichtig was kann rein
was muss raus das habe ich dann der
bühne frank zusammen entschieden und es
war schon teilweise ja sehr anstrengen
und das ist übrigens marcel das ist auch
im see kreativer kopf da hält uns
momentan den rücken frei und schneidet
gerade all unsere youtube-videos und
alles was noch ansteht und hier seht ihr
ihn gerade wie er das making of videos
schneidet ich habe jetzt kann man sagen
es ist unser baby war ja so weh von
sozial- und unsere freunde dieses
gedreht haben dann alles was wir gemacht
haben dann die ganze
ich ein produkt und es gab es im
fernsehen auch noch nicht dass die frau
die eine vorder kamera steht auch
gleichzeitig im schnitt dabei ist alles
plant alles macht er und das ist halt
das was wir machen wollen wir hatten
echt die zirkus selber in der hand haben
das ganze hier produziert und ich freue
mich jetzt schon zu viel will ich
eigentlich gar nicht verraten
ich hoffe dass wir euch jetzt einen
kleinen einblick hinter die kulissen
geben konnten und ihr am sonntag um 15
uhr einschalteten am sonntag um 15 uhr
ist torten zeit bei vox und dass die
nächsten vier sonntage genau welche sage
jetzt vielleicht weiter könnten jetzt
leitungsbau gebaut
ich glaube nein jedenfalls habe ich mir
jetzt folgendes vorgestellt am sonntag
um 11 uhr kommt bei mir auf meinem
youtube kanal ein ganz normales rezept
video
ich habe mir einen richtig tollen
zupfkuchen ausgesucht und ich werde euch
jetzt hier im anschluss gleich die
zutaten vorstellen dann könnt ihr euch
nämlich die zutaten kaufen könnte am
sonntag um 11 uhr gemeinsam mit mir dann
die sind kuchen backen und pünktlich
dann um 15 uhr mit kaffee und kuchen die
sendung genießen
jetzt machen wir das ja also schaltet
auf jeden fall ein am sonntag um 15 uhr
da ist trockenzeit verbockt zunächst nur
nachts gut problems kann enttäuscht und
wie kommt unserem team auf wiedersehen
[Musik]